happy to find this particular one good
afternoon and welcome to at Yale live
I'm Eric curse on Vikings good guys bad
guys who were these people
today really where horn helmets what
lasting effects do they have on human
society and culture honors win Ross
professor of history at Yale and an
expert in the Vikings joins us today to
set the record straight his next book a
new history of the Viking Age is
expected from Princeton University Press
in 2014 honors thank you for being with
us thank you thank you for inviting me
so let me ask you to start with a
definition who were the Vikings who were
these people how did they distinguish
themselves from other groups of people
roaming the earth at the time right
well the Vikings were essentially
Scandinavia's most of them are
Scandinavians they there is sometimes a
tendency to call anybody who's vaguely
northern European and vaguely early
medieval for a Viking but I don't really
like I think I should reserve the term
Viking for those Scandinavians who went
out to plunder and rage in the rest of
Europe there is sometimes there were
there were other people who joined them
we don't know very much about it but it
it stands to reason that that they would
have or they would have people people
joining these successful bands of
warriors when it when it when it was
convenient and then worried us in time a
little bit what is the viking era if one
can refer to such a thing
well it's traditionally said it goes
from 793 to 1066 is when i wanted to
have from the first big raid on a
monastery outside north of New Castle in
Northeast in England in 793 Lynda's
Varna to 1066 the the last serious
invasion attempt of a Scandinavian ruler
to take England three weeks before
William the Conqueror the Norwegian
Herald hard ruler was killed and thrown
back but it exhausted anglo-saxon army
and that probably had a great deal to do
with why they lost at Hastings three
weeks later so the popular conception of
the Vikings as
as travelers and as Raiders is not
inaccurate know they they they did do
this they were violent but it's not the
only thing Scandinavians did in the
early Middle Ages they the early
medieval Scandinavians were like a lot
of people are have are and have been in
and various times in history there are
great opportunities they took the
opportunities that they saw when they
saw them and if the opportunity was to
trade they traded if it was to raid they
raided he was supposed to settle down
and plow the fields they did that too
you know I'm gonna go back to the
definition for a second you you've
refers them as Scandinavians yes
primarily to what extent can we
associate them with the people who live
in scandia Scandinavia today well the
that should would be I mean they are
probably related that is these were
people who are living in what today is
Norway Sweden Denmark yes okay Finland
Iceland and so forth yes and you know in
a place like Iceland they have this
wonderful you know logical database
where you could actually look up who
you're related to and and you know
everybody's relating related to all
these famous Viking Age heroes what
drove them to leave Scandinavia well I
don't think I don't like to think of it
as much as leaving something I think of
it as something that pulling them in
Europe pulled them in Europe had things
that they wanted one of the things that
was really needed that the Scandinavians
felt they really needed was was wealth
so when they when he noticed that there
there was more or less unguarded wealth
to be had for instance in Lindisfarne a
monastery or there all the church
vessels and so forth that that had a
very powerful pull on them to come and
just take it because it was there for
the taking now was this was this wealth
that they sought to meet basic needs or
was this wealth more to meet desires I
think the latter is is is is more
correct I think it's although it's a
really about it's about politics it's
about political economy that if we go
back to 800 900 or so you didn't have
kingdoms in Scandinavia you didn't
really have any any real political
organization what you did have was that
you had powerful people chieftains who
tried to get more power and how do you
get power when there is no state when
you know you can't stand up for election
or something well you need to have
warriors around you and then you can
persuade people to do the things you
want them to do so they wanted to have
as many warriors as possible how do you
get warriors when you when you can't
just call in the army as a king when you
have to make people want to work for you
and the way you get you get them to want
to work for you is that you you get a
good relationship with them and you that
or you dominate them right we dominate
them but it's in the first place your
warriors you won't have a good
relationship with it because you don't
want them to be angry at you so we
invite them for parties there's always
great need drinking around midwinter and
when they come to the parties you give
them gifts armorings of gold and silver
but if you're going to do that you're
pretty soon going to run out of gold and
silver that's when you get the brilliant
idea I can go to this monastery and get
some more golden silver and that's what
they did now how did he know about you
know that there was a monastery in
Linda's foreigner or there was a
monastery there were monasteries up and
down you know the Scottish or English or
French coast
they must have they must have done they
must have it they must have just gone
and explored right yeah yeah I mean they
they they did Scandinavians had not been
sitting at home in Scandinavia and
counting their sheep or whatever you
know that they they you always had trade
you always had when the Roman Roman
Empire was still going strong you had
Scandinavia serving as mercenaries in
the woman armies the the historian
Giordano's who lived in Constantinople
today Istanbul in around 550 says that
or the Swedes trade with first they sent
beautiful first was
kena Naviance did move around before
that so they knew what what was what
what the rest of Europe looked like at
least approximately and how far was
their reach east and west because I as I
understand it it wasn't it wasn't
strictly Europe right no they I mean one
of the one of the most fascinating
aspects of the Viking Age I think is all
the people who moved away from mainland
Scandinavia to you know England to
Iceland and then eventually to Greenland
which of course is in North America and
from green and they actually moved to to
North America there is there is bona
fide a Scandinavian settlement or no
Newfoundland so that's as far as they
got they might have gotten got an even
further but we can't know that because
you know what would be the good places
to to saddle in the Viking Age well New
Haven would be a good place but you know
we are not going to find those those
remnants because New Haven has been
built for hundreds of years
in the East they went all the way to
Asia there they had regular trading
deals with this town called bull gar
which is you know about a day's travel
by train east of Moscow in the 11th
century there is good evidence that a
Swedish chieftain went down to the
caspian sea and attacked the Arab
Caliphate on the south coast of the
Caspian Sea he was killed and everybody
with him now if I get my jog referred
the Caspian Sea is an inland sea yes
right so the the Vikings would have had
to travel over land right okay so they
were not strictly seafaring people but
they traveled on the rivers mmm if you
think of Russia Russia is pretty flat so
the rivers are broad and and float and
float slowly flow so it slowly so what
they did was that they they sort of got
smaller boats and and rowed upstream on
the Baltic Sea side up to the middle of
Russia and then they they hold the ship
over land to the next river to the Volga
for instance
and then they they say downstream into
the Caspian Sea if they could get that
far honors I'm going to take a question
from a viewer quickly this is from Jesse
Leavenworth and he writes to ask what
did the Vikings look like were they
short were they tall would with the
Raiders among them be the strongest what
do we know about about what these people
look like well they'd looked like early
medieval people in general I'm sure they
looked a little bit more like
Scandinavians than southern Europeans we
know something about their stature and
and you know they were not they were not
tall I mean they were not 2 meter or six
feet tall as Scandinavia's often are
today they were short about everybody
was exactly yes it's funny one thinks of
Vikings as this match of man who are
really strong and really all that but if
you look at the skeletons they have all
kinds of diseases as everybody had in in
in the early Middle Ages they they they
have bad teeth they had they broke legs
they broke bones and so forth presumably
they were mostly men I think so yes I
mean there must have been women with
them yeah there surely was the war
there were a lot of stories about female
fighters about shield maidens about
value yes
these are stories written down in
especially in Iceland in the High Middle
Ages so this is like two three hundred
years later that in the 13th century the
14th century wonderful stories that talk
about shield amazing Emma were
essentially Amazon's
so you know it's always very hard to
figure out what is literary imagination
and what is reality interesting and we
have another question from a viewer
along the same lines and this person
wrote to us by Twitter at handle uh MH
AF izh C which I won't attempt to
pronounce the the questions are
there are other actual remains of
Vikings and and perhaps elaborate on
that a little bit
what is the archaeological record like
for the Vikings there is an enormous
archaeological record especially all
around a loose cannon a via where
there's been a lot of digs done in
Viking Age sides but also also in in you
know various places in Europe and has
found in in northern part of the British
Isles when has found a man buried in
boats which looked just like Viking
Viking burial when these mass graves or
this individual whether mass graves to
the individual graves and massacres and
this is huge mass grave in in a place
called Repton in England which I don't
remember is something like 200 people
buried there
and it looks like the what what one
things now is that they were struck by
some kind of epidemic epidemics they
died from from disease I should have
said that this is famous we know from
from from written sources there was a
Viking encampment thereand at some point
I think in the 10th century and it looks
like many of them died and it doesn't
look like they died off or violence that
you know some kind of disease got into
the camp and they they just die
deliberate in a huge mass grave but in
the middle of of it all there's a
particularly large man buried in a
particularly spectacular very a leader
of some sort yes it looks like that but
we don't really know exactly how to
interpret it
but it will all around Scandinavia one
one there are many many interesting
things there in Norway in the 1920s they
dug up two entire bones Viking ships in
Norway
yes which are very well preserved in
Roskilde in Denmark they dug up five
poorly preserved Viking Age ships in in
the 20th century as well all around
Sweden there are there is something like
3,000 or all around scary name is
something like 3,000 inscriptions in
stone from the Viking Age so it sounds
like there's a lot to work with relative
to a literary texts of one sort or
another how does the archaeological
record figure in your own work about
I am I'm first and foremost a historian
I'm trained in in working with with
written remnants of the past but of
course to work with Vikings one has to
know archaeology so most of my reading
is okay not even there's very little
written evidence or from Scandinavia
itself from the Viking Age there's the
rune stones and there's some poetry that
was written down later on there's plenty
of evidence from Europe all these
chronicles and so forth that were
written by usually by monks and other
clerics who were the victims who whether
wisdoms indeed and they're not happy
about no I can't imagine so so
presumably these victims were leaving
written texts are partially responsible
perhaps for the reputation and the
popular imagination we have even today
in the 21st century of the Vikings as
Raiders and plunderers and extremely
violent people yes exactly I mean that
that you get the perspective of the
victims yeah all the time I don't think
the Vikings were any particularly more
violent than anybody else's time in fact
they were they were they operated in a
small scale so they you know they didn't
kill that many at the same time at the
same time as you know famous people like
Charlemagne had over 3,000 Germans
executed in a single day in 789 the
Vikings were just amateurs compared to
that but you know Charlemagne had a huge
arm and and a huge state let me press
you just a little bit on the the
literacy of the Vikings to make sure
that I understand this this is a
illiterate people yeah but yet they
haven't left a whole lot behind in terms
of literature well they they there were
people among the Scandinavians who could
read and write me probably more than we
think they did have stories they told
each other stories which were you know
continued to be taught over the
centuries until they were written down
in the 2013-14 century we don't know
that the true story written down in the
13th century is the same story as was
told in the 10th of course they're
probably not
but they certainly were people with
imagination and and and literary talent
we can see this in the in the rune
stones and in the poetry which survives
from the time this were not these these
are these are sophisticated literary
monuments the poetry's is fascinating is
actually can be very very hard to
understand because they don't call a
spade a spade the sword is not a sword a
sword is you know the snake of the
battle because it looks like a sad or or
to kill somebody is well instead of
saying I killed a lot of people or you
killed a lot of people in battle of that
day you say or the husband of the
she-wolf did not go hungry that winter
how in other words the wolf eats cancer
there's sort of a poetic people in a way
yes yes no Saturday poetry was very
highly valued let's talk about the
spread of the Vikings a little bit it's
my understanding that they would raid
and plunder and in many of the the
places where they went and visited and
settled temporarily they then eventually
left and went back to Scandinavia and in
other places such as perhaps in Normandy
and Iceland they stayed and became part
of the cultures there yes how does
Iceland stand out among all these places
that they visited and perhaps settled
more permanently well Iceland they
definitely stayed permanently there
Iceland is is still a country where
we're a Scandinavian language is spoken
and it's also spoken in in it's it's the
Scandinavian language that's closest to
the Old Norse spoken by the Vikings so
it's it's sort of interesting as you
know I have studied all Norse and then I
come to Iceland then people speak
something like what I have learned of
course the language has developed it
yeah so it's actually very hard to pick
up things not to mention that I did when
I studied all noise I didn't learn words
for newspaper and I think like that
but but it's it's a wonderful country
have a section on Iceland last week you
were yes so it was this a pleasure or a
research trip it it was a research trip
I I looked at this is a sort of non
biking related thing I looked at the the
use of law in the late medieval
Icelandic shirt courts so so that was
that was very nice my girlfriend is
Icelandic - oh okay all right so it was
there were some pleasure as well good
good
so is it fair to say then that the
contemporary people of Iceland are the
the group that most closely approximates
or was most closely descended from
clearly the the Vikings well they
certainly speak the most Viking lightly
arch and what's also fascinating but but
Iceland is that that they have this you
know logical database where where you if
you're a nice lender you can log in and
look up and see how you're related to
aliens Gallegly yeah or any of the
famous Viking Age heroes from the
literature of course not everything in
that database especially their earlier
parts of it might be historically
correct but it's Lisa's reproduces what
the what the sagas the the wonderful
high medieval Icelandic literature says
about these people let's take another
question from viewers this one comes
from Austin Gunnar
Nanook Woodruff and he asks what makes
the Vikings so exciting and interesting
to you how did this become one of your
specialties as a scholar well I mean I I
think this is part of the reason is I'm
Swedish so I grew up in Sweden and you
know elementary school we learned about
these things we read some you know some
of the stories and and so forth and then
I went off to become a historian I did
not write my dissertation about about my
case I wrote my dissertation about
medieval legal history
but then I I found my way back to the
Vikings because I thought it was very
interesting and I thought there were
things that need that I wanted to
explore to myself I want you to know
more about it so that's it's really
after curiosity that that I've been
pursuing this and have you discovered
anything has your understanding expanded
in such a way in ways that surprised you
that is is there anything that you found
out about the Vikings that you didn't
expect to find out well I I think I
think the basic surprise was was what
I've already been mentioning is that you
learn about Vikings you think about my
kings as these violent people who were
you know really they really wanted to do
violence there's so much more to the
story
mhm and these parts of the stories are
the ones that have been most surprised
about and most fascinating I mean just
such a fact that in in Sweden alone
there's over a hundred thousand Arabs
silver coin from the Viking Age found in
the ground every year somebody finds
hundreds if not thousands of Arab silver
coins from the Viking Age in the Swedish
ground now that must tell us something
yeah
and it's it's it's fascinating to to
think about for you obviously it could
simply be coins right that were brought
back by the Vikings but is there any
indication that Arabs were travelling
also to what is now Scandinavia well
there is actually there is actually one
account of a man who who who came from
Tortosa in Spain which was done in the
in the Arab in an Arab Caliphate who
went as far as as what used to be
Southern Denmark now is northwestern
Germany asmik probably not the the I
think this these coins came to
Scandinavia through trade mainly and
trade was done through intermediaries
Scandinavians will probably go to this
place bulgor in in sort of well a bit
east of Moscow and Arabs would go to
Bangor and they would meet there
and exchanged the Scandinavians would
sell fur and slaves and the Paris would
pay with silver and gold let's debunk
what is probably a myth but you would
know did the Vikings really wear horned
helmets no they didn't and actually if
you just think about it a little bit it
doesn't make much sense if you're
fighting with swords and axes you don't
want a helmet from which something juts
out because then is very easy to deal
with you
so does the archaeological record
you know indicate that is through
absence of such things yes
they just weren't there that they
weren't there it's it's actually sort of
a tavern in 19th century
misinterpretation of the horns that look
like drinking horns that was thought to
be this and then it you know it was
bargainers richard wagner's the dress
designer in thyroid in 1876 to the world
premiere of the Ring des Nibelungen that
put horned helmets on the heroes of that
story some of them come from this
Scandinavian literature it's easy to see
how it's remained part of the popular
image because it does fit it does make
them look look the part almost of yes
waiters and it's it's a it's an
immediately recognizable this visual
symbol or visual signal so so what
happened to the Vikings that is why
don't why don't we why aren't there
Vikings today well it depends on how you
define Vikings there are some people who
like to think that our bike is different
if you define them as the people who
raided and plundered in Europe the
reason why that stopped is that the
European European kingdoms got their act
together and God got organized and got
the defense's organized so in that sense
that the Viking sort of had an important
impact on European history because it
forced European Kings to organize their
states or their kingdoms which which got
them to start taking up fees from their
their subjects and so forth I sometimes
jokingly say that the the Vikings
brought death death and taxes to you
because they forced the Kings to take up
taxes so they could organ
nice their defenses so that's why they
disappeared I mean Harold Harold hard
ruler attacking England in 1066 he was
defeated several other Scandinavians
were tried to attack England before that
they actually succeeded there was the
Danish people being kings of England for
20-25 years earlier in the 11th century
so they they became more peaceable and
this sort of defining characteristics of
traveling and raiding and plundering and
so on it wasn't a necessary activity for
them anymore so they sort of became more
domestic well I'm not sure about that
there I mean they could continue to
attack in the East but in the East we
had nobody writing down anything about
it you know Sweden attacked Finland in
the middle of the 12th century it's a
famous story in Swedish history dan
market attacked Estonia in the in the
12th or 13th centuries a battle in
Estonia when the Danish flag supposedly
fell down from the skies that's what the
Danish flags goes back to it's one of
the oldest flags in Europe so they just
directed their energies in other
directions but in in general it is true
that that and this is actually true for
all of European history that the passage
from the early Middle Ages to the high
and late Middle Ages is the passage from
political structure where you attack
aliens people outside your own group and
take their wealth to period where you
turn inside and you take with the wealth
from your subjects in other words taxes
let's plunder in the early middle is
that Texas in the in the higher late
Middle Ages this is a gross
simplification but that's basically how
it works another question coming in this
one from Lou Auguste and he asks if
you've heard of the Maine penny and if
it's really a hoax if you have heard of
it is it a real deal or is it a hoax
it's it's maybe define what it is for
yes it's it's it's a penny which is the
the basic measurement of of money in the
Middle Ages it's a penny that was found
in Maine right maybe yes
don't remember exactly when it was found
and if this it is clearly a 12th century
Norwegian penny struck by a Norwegian
King there's no doubt about that the
question is what does it that mean
because you know if you if your
grandfather dropped a Norwegian penny in
in 1920 we don't know where it comes
from we don't have the archaeological
context so it doesn't prove really
anything it's very likely that this
penny had reached whoever lived in Maine
and in the in the thirteenth 12th 13th
century through some kind of exchange
trade or or otherwise and that it has
been there since then but we don't know
because we don't know how it was found
or where it was found
yeah let's talk about the book you are
working on which comes out from
Princeton yes 2014 or so 2014 yes tell
us about the book when I'm very excited
about about this book I have been
teaching Viking history at Yale for four
have been at the 8th for 15 years and
and this I'm sharing what I have learned
in this process with I hope now a larger
audience than than than just my classes
as it were and I am trying to take a new
grip on the Viking Age that's why I call
it a new history of the Viking Age and I
hope that that people will be excited to
read it is there a principle argument
that you're advancing well there there's
it's not it doesn't have a big argument
it has many small arguments I mean some
of which we touched on here you know
this I want to argue that there there
isn't something a really exceptional
about the Vikings the Vikings just
behaved the way early medieval people
behaved there are some aspects of their
history that are very fascinating to us
but they were no more violent than than
anybody else there were no less
civilized than anybody else and and so
forth a day you I what I want to do is I
want to broaden invite people to
think broadly about early medieval
Scandinavian culture and what the
Vikings and their castles were doing at
the time question coming in from
Alejandro Drago hope I pronounced that
all right how did Christianity relate to
or affect the end of the Viking culture
that's a very good question because I
think it actually had a lot to do with
it and that's actually the subject of my
or my last book the the conversion of
Scandinavia Vikings merchants and
missionaries in the remaking of northern
Europe that came out last year on on
Yale University Press the the
Christianity came to Scandinavia because
these leaders chieftains Kings would be
Kings thought that Christianity was a
useful religion to have and Christianity
helped them to become kingdoms to get a
few of the shifters won the competition
with others and became kings and they
had a Christianity helped to create the
kingdoms that we know from the Middle
Ages Sweden Norway and Denmark and that
helped that made meant that they became
more organized and it meant that when
when it stopped being really possible to
go to Western Europe to steal wealth
these kingdoms started to tax no their
subjects instead interesting we're
running out of time but I want to ask
you one more question in you were
MacArthur Fellow in 2003 yes um and I
wonder how has that experience sort of
shaped your work and whether it has very
much to do be that the the I was very
grateful to get to MacArthur in 2003 it
gave me some it put off it lifted some
pressure from it gave me some some time
to really read up on what actually was a
new subject I mean I had not started
Viking history in graduate school and
not much in college either even though I
went to college in Scholl and it gave me
some breathing space where I could sit
down and read and read and read about
the Viking Age and that is something
that I'm intensely
grateful for that I was able to do and
and I I don't think I would have written
either of these books without the
McArthur interesting we are going to
take one more question
this is tweeted to us by at Mimi her see
and she asks what do you think of the
History Channel's Vikings program
alright I've seen the two first episodes
I what I really loved about that show is
that that clearly the person who wrote
the script has read the sources because
there are details in the in the in the
show there's for instance in one of the
two first episodes as a point where you
have again a man who wash themselves in
in in in a ball that that is handing
around by a servant girl and they all
wash themselves and then they blow their
nose in it and that's exactly what it
says in a in a 921 report by an Arab who
had gone north to bulgur and met some
people who seem to have been
Scandinavians so they I really like that
they pick up on things like that but I
don't I don't I don't watch drama for
historical accuracy I watch drama for
drama yeah so that that's that's sort of
a different story as it were well that's
great and we'll all have to watch The
History Channel I'm glad to know they're
doing their homework I want to thank you
so much for joining us today to talk
about the Vikings I don't want to thank
all of you for watching at Yale live
we'll look forward to seeing you next
time bye-bye
you
you